so stand up comedy is it a metaphor for
something in our lives is it I just
think it's another form of entertainment
yeah and it's it's very very directed
say here's the stuff that makes me crazy
I want to talk to somebody about it
there's you love standup there's a
documentary that HBO did a couple years
ago about this little boom that happened
in the 80s in Boston and stand up that
got its Larry all these Stephen Stephen
right all these people came out of
Boston you should try to get that and
watch it I bet it's on netflix I can't
the other name it exhausting in the
title that I don't remember the name of
that is really good it was on HBO a
couple years ago and now we go through
these periods were stand-up is like the
thing and then it sort of takes a
backseat for a while but I think it's a
form of entertainment the wall always be
there you know there's a real problem
about stand up right now because of TV
and especially the internet that there
were people who would live on their 15
minutes and go from town to town imma do
it now you go on TV when you do your 15
minutes and everybody hears it you got
to have something new when you put it on
YouTube and there you go so you're
constantly now having to write plus
everybody has exposure to your stuff and
you know there are just so many things
that you can come up with about you know
our starbucks I mean cheese you know
this this and those chinos and you know
it's got fluffy stuff how many things
can you do about that and so many people
are doing it so this order there's a
real problem nail it coming up with
interesting new material that different
observations on life that other people
don't have because there's so so so much
it's against out
you